hi in this module i'm going to talk
about probabilistic programming new way
to think about defining bayesian
networks through the lens of writing
programs and this really is going to
highlight the generative process aspect
of bayesian networks
so recall in bayesian networks is
defined by a set of variables
there are directed edges between the
random variables that capture
qualitative relationships
then for every variable
we define a local conditional
distribution condition on the parents of
that variable
you multiply all these together and you
get the joint distribution over all the
random
and then given this joint distribution
as a probabilistic database you can go
and do probabilistic inference and
answer all sorts of questions
so what we're going to focus on today is
how to write down this
joint distribution or via the beijing
network
so we're going to look at it in a you
via the lens of programs let's go
through this example so let me write a
short program that i claim is going to
be equivalent to writing down either
this ex this
equation or drawing this graph
so here it goes
so first i'm going to draw b from a
bernoulli distribution
so you can think about this as the
bernoulli is just a function
that
it snaps on
and returns
one with or true with probability
epsilon
so b is going to be set to 1 or true
with a probability epsilon
i'm going to independently do the same
for e
and then finally i'm going to set a
equals b for e so if i run this program
it's going to produce a setting to a
b and b
so in general a project program is just
a randomized program such that if you
run it it sets the random variables
and in particular it produces an
assignment to the random variable
so
while you can run the program it's
useful to think about the program itself
as just a mathematical construct that's
used to define
a distribution in particular the
probability of a program producing a
particular assignment is going to be
if by definition the joint distribution
over that assignment
so let's look at a more interesting
example that showcases the convenience
of using programming
so this one's going to have a for loop
in it so let's say we're doing object
tracking so we're going to assume that
there's some object that starts
at 0 0
and then for each time step 1 through n
i'm going to
with probability
alpha
i'm going to go right so i minus 1 x i
minus 1 is a previous location i'm going
to add 1 comma 0 to it
i'm going to go right
or
with probably one minus alpha i'm going
to go down
so here is the
bayesian network corresponding to this
probabilistic program so you can see
that each x i depends only on x i minus
one
the cool part is that this is a program
and we can actually run this so this is
implemented in javascript behind scenes
and you click run
with alpha equals 0.5 and each run
produces an assignment x1 x2 x3 x4 and
so on
to the random variables and we can
visualize them
and you can play with alpha if alpha
equals two
then
um actually let's make this point one
then
i actually need to press ctrl enter to
save if it's point one then all the
trajectories are going to be over here
it's point nine
then the trajectories are
so this
program
is specifies what is called a markov
model which is a special case of a
bayesian network where
we have a chain each variable is only
dependent on the previous
so
with this markup model we can ask
particular questions for example what
are the possible trajectories given
the evidence x10 equals h2
so here
i'm going to condition on
x10 equals a2
and if i run this then i'm sampling from
all the program traces where i restrict
only those ones where x10 is clamped to
a2
so this is a way to visualize
the conditional distribution
of a problem 6 program
so now i'm going to quickly go through
a set of examples of bayesian networks
and by using probabilistic programs to
write them down
um so this is going to be a fairly broad
uh and quick overview um
so one
another my application is in language
modeling which is often used to score
sentences
for speech recognition or machine
translation
so here is a probabilistic program
for each position in the sentence we're
going to generate a word x i
given i minus one so this is actually in
nlp it's called a bi-gram or more
generally n-gram
model
so here we generate x1 maybe that's rec
and generate x2 given x1 maybe that's ah
and made x3 give an x2 that's nice and
x4 given x3 that's beach
so here is an example of object tracking
which that's actually we're going to
study at length in future modules
this is called a hidden markov model
um so here for every time step equals
one to big t
i'm going to generate an object location
ht
so for example h1 i'm going to generate
3 1
and then i'm going to also generate a
sensor reading et
given ht
so given h1 i'm going to generate
um e1
and i might get something like just the
sum of coordinates uh
example
and then i'm gonna move to the next time
step generate h2 given h1 um
maybe that's three two i'm going to
generate a sensor reading which is some
of the coordinates and then so on
generate h3 generate e3 turn h4 e4 and
ray h5e
so that specifies the joint distribution
over these
object locations
and sensor readings and now a canonical
question you might want to ask is given
the sensor readings where is the object
so here is a generalization
of the hmm to allow for multiple object
tracking it's called a factorial hmm
so here for every time step now i'm
going to have two objects a and b
and i'm going to generate the location
of object o at time step t
um for example here i have
h 1 a
and h 1 b
and i'm going to generate a single
sensor reading
which depends on both the objects
so here i have e1
condition on both
h1a and
go
h1b
the next time step
generate the object locations
for
the two objects and then generate the
sensor reading condition on those two
objects
transition to the third time step
generate the sensor reading transition
to the fourth time step
sensor reading
so in general this defines a joint
distribution now overall
the object locations for both objects as
well as the corresponding sensor reading
so here is another uh classic example
called naive bayes which is often used
for
a very fast classification
so the way naive phase works is that
we're going to
generate a class or a label y
example in document classification i
might generate that this document is
going to be about travel
and then for each position in the
document
i'm going to generate a word wi
so for this one i might generate a beach
um
second word my general paris
um and then
all the way up to wl
so now the typical way you uh um
use these database models is that you're
given a text document which is the
sequence of words you asked for
the label what is this document
so a fancier version of the naive phase
model is
called laying dirichlet allocation
and here we're going to assume that a
document is not just about one topic but
possibly multiple topics so i'm going to
generate a distribution over topics
called alpha notice that this is
actually a continuous
random variable a might take on
uh values um
which uh assigns probability 0.8 to
travel 1.2 to europe
and then for again for each us element
in the document each position i
and generate a topic
zi
so here i might generate um
travel for z1
i'm going to generate a word
given that topic so here w1
um given the d1 let me carry the beach
then move on to the next word generate a
topic generate a word given the topic
and so on and so forth before i reach
the end
document
okay so the typical way you would
uh use lda is that you're given a text
document
the words here
what topics is it about
i want to infer what are the topics for
each of the words but also the topic
distribution for that
so here is another example which
generalizes the bayesian network that we
actually saw in a previous module
so
in general let's suppose that
you have a bunch of diseases
we're going to generate for each disease
di which is the activity of disease high
so we might have pneumonia generator 1
cold and malaria
um
and we're going to have a set of
symptoms and symptoms
where each symptom would generate an
activity
of that symptom sj
we might have fever
which depends on
the diseases
and we might have a cough which depends
on the set of diseases and we have
vomiting which depends on the diseases
so now the way you typically use this
visual network is that a patient comes
in
and reports some symptoms
um you ask the question what diseases
might they have
and i'll just point out that this is a
case where missing information can be
handled naturally if you a patient
doesn't have
um you if you didn't record a particular
symptom
then you can just
ignore that variable
so here is another example
motivation is that you have a social
network you want to analyze
why certain people are connected with
other people
so the model is formally called a
sarcastic block model
the idea is that for each person
we're going to generate a type of that
person
so maybe we have three people a
politician a scientist
and another scientist
and then for every pair of people we're
going to generate
whether those two people are connected
eij is a boolean
whether
this
politician and the scientist
um
might be connected there's a one
and the generation of this only depends
on the types
of the two people in consideration
so
two and three
are scientists and they're connected and
this politician and this scientist
are not connected
so remember we are given
the social network which
are
just the connectivity structures so
these e's
and we're asked what is the probability
of
the people
being of certain types
so
that was a whirlwind tour of a lot of
different bayesian popular bayesian
network
architectures in the literature
but they all basically boil down to this
one which is that there is
a variable or a set of variables h
which are generated first and then
giving rise to a set of
variables e
so the probabilistic program
specifies a bayesian network by running
it it gives you a joint assignment and
the probability of producing that
uh joint assignment is the joint
probability
there are many many types of models i've
only given you a very small subsample of
them
but the
i want you to take away from this a
general
uh
paradigm
is that you come up with stories
of how quantities of interest
each um
generate the data that you observe
e
so this is really the opposite of how
you normally think about machine
learning or classification where you
start with the inputs and then you
define a sequence of operations to
produce the outputs
invasion networks often it's reversed
you think about the quantities of
interest first
how they might arise in the world and
then how
the data is generated from those
quantity of interest
so this paradigm might take a little bit
of getting used to but it might become
natural after some practice all right
that's in